good morning
I'm Jeff Berman United States Attorney
for the Southern District of New York
today we announce the unsealing of sex
trafficking charges against Jeffrey
Epstein
the charges allege that Epstein sexually
abused young girls by enticing them to
engage in sex acts for money Epstein was
arrested this past Saturday evening at
Teterboro Airport aboard his private jet
that had just landed from Paris France
Epstein was taken to the Metropolitan
Correctional Center in Manhattan and
later today he will be presented before
Magistrate Judge Pittman and later a
conference before District Court judge
Berman
the United States Attorney's Office will
take the position at that presentment
and that conference that Epstein should
be detained pending trial
Epstein is charged in a two count
indictment first conspiracy to commit
sex trafficking and second the
substantive crime of sex trafficking of
underage girls beginning at at least
2002 and continuing until 2005 Epstein
is alleged to have abused dozens of
victims by causing them to engage in sex
acts with him at his mansion in New York
and at his estate in Palm Beach Florida
the victims were all underage girls at
the time of the alleged conduct were
given hundreds of dollars in cash after
each encounter either by Epstein or by
one of Epstein's employees the underage
girls were initially recruited to
provide Epstein with massages and often
did so nude or partially nude these
massages became increasingly sexual in
nature that would typically include one
or more sex acts as specified in the
indictment as alleged Epstein also paid
certain victims to recruit additional
girls to be similarly abused
this allowed Epstein
to create an ever-expanding web of new
victims this conduct as alleged went on
for years and involved dozens of young
girls some as young as 14 years old at
the time that they were allegedly abused
as alleged Epstein was well aware that
many of his victims reminders and not
surprisingly many of the underage girls
that Epstein allegedly victimized were
particularly vulnerable to exploitation
the alleged behavior shocks the
conscience and while the charged conduct
is from a number of years ago it is
still profoundly important to the many
alleged victims now young women they
deserve their day in court and we are
proud to be standing up for them by
bringing this indictment combating sex
trafficking and exploitation of children
is a priority for this office and for
the Department of Justice as the sexual
abuse of a minor can have devastating
effects on victims often lasting for
years
that is why my office will not rest
until perpetrators of these types of
crimes are brought to justice
victims voices including the many voices
of Epstein's alleged victims must be
heard to that end I want to say to
anyone who is watching this or hearing
about our prosecution if you believe you
are a victim of men and Jeffrey Epstein
or you have evidence or information from
aiding to the contact alleged in the
indictment unsealed today we want to
hear from you please call 1-800 FBI
that's 1-800 call let's be up
the charges unsealed today reflect the
hard work not only in this office but by
our law enforcement partners at the
Federal Bureau of Investigation to my
left is pill sweetie the assistant
director in charge of the New York field
office of the FBI and I wish to thank
him and his team for their dedication
and professionalism and seeing this
investigation through I also want to
thank the New York City Police
Department represented here today by
Chief Jason Wilcox and Customs and
Border Patrol for their assistance in
this investigation and I want to thank
and acknowledge the career prosecutors
of my office handling the investigation
and prosecution of this case tonight
right now it's Ross Miller
Alison BOE Rory and Colby and their
supervisors in the public corruption
unit Russell Capone and Edward discount
it is a privilege for me everyday the
work with these bright talented and
dedicated public servants the talent is
unbelievable we will continue to devote
significant resources to investigating
these crimes that's protecting young
people from sexual predators and now I
would like to invite bill Sweeney up to
the podium thanks chef good morning
preserving the innocence of children is
one of the most important
responsibilities we carry as adults
purposely failing children in any way is
not an option yet there are some in
society who have chosen to blatantly
disregard this responsibility using
whatever means they have at their
disposal to lure children into a life
which they should never have been
exposed as we allege today Jeffrey
Epstein is one of those people at
approximately 5:30 p.m. on Saturday
evening we arrested him at Teterboro
Airport without incident Epstein has
been charged with one count each of sex
trafficking and sex trafficking
conspiracy
for at least a four year period covering
the entirety of 2002 through 2005 he is
alleged to have sexually exploited and
abused dozens of minor girls at his
homes in New York City and in Palm Beach
Florida
the girls were recruited in a variety of
ways usually by employees of Epstein and
sometimes by fellow victims the victims
typically received hundreds of dollars
in cash the estimated dozens of victims
or as young as 14 years old at time of
recruitment children who provided
Epstein massages while they were nude or
partially nude children who are asked to
engage in direct and indirect sex acts
for money children who were enticed to
do all these things at the hands of a
man more than or nearly three times
their age those who have been victimized
by child sexual predators are frequently
haunted by memories of these crimes well
into their adulthood often for the rest
of their lives they bear the burden of
someone else's criminal behavior too
often adults in our society have turned
a blind eye to this type of criminal
behavior alleged here we have seen the
excuses the ignorance of many who didn't
even bother to understand that this
behavior is this persistent scourge
against our society's vulnerable youth
and the willful blindness as to who the
real villains are in this type of
outrageous crime the villains are the
adult perpetrators not the children
victims of child sex trafficking come
from all walks of life they are our
neighbors our students young adults
looking for help vulnerable foster
children the list goes on and on and on
to the victims who may be listening or
get word of today's charges the team
standing here before you represents FBI
Special Agents NYPD detectives analyst
victim specialist prosecutors who make
it their mission to listen to every
individual who's been exploited and to
advocate for the most vulnerable among
us we are parents we are community
members we are human beings but as an
FBI special agent and the head of this
office I
have the privilege to represent and
stand among many who make it our mission
to put prior predators behind bars where
they belong
regardless of the Predators power wealth
or perceived connections today I'm
asking everyone to take a good look at
this man if you have been victimized in
any way or if you are somebody who has
any additional information about his
alleged illegal behavior we want to hear
from you whatever age you are now
whatever age you were then no matter
where or when the incident or incidents
took place the number to call is
guidelines prohibit us from talking
about such individuals and so I just
want to let you know that if that
question comes up about any individual
my answer will be no comment and that
would be across the board no comment and
I urge you not to read anything into
that one way or the other there any
questions yes Jeffrey Epstein entered
into a non-prosecution agreement with
the Southern District of Florida that
agreement only binds by its terms only
vines in Southern District of Florida
the Southern District of New York is not
bound by that agreement and is not a
signatory to that agreement well I'm not
getting into the staffing decisions at
the US Attorney's Office I will say that
I have confidence that the public
corruption unit is able it can easily
handle this investigation prosecution as
it has so many other matters I will
again urge you not to read into the unit
assignment anything one way or another
with respect to the investigation look
I'm not going to comment right now on
the evidence I will say that we are
going to request detention pending the
trial in this case I'm not going into
any dealings with Maine justice nor am I
going to go into any aspects of how our
investigation originated I will say that
we were assisted from some excellent
investigative journalism I won't comment
on getting back at anybody or anything
that's not the way we work we work with
facts when the facts presented
themselves is mr. Behrman hinted at
through investigative journalists work
we moved on it now I'm talking about
society in the hole we've seen sex
trafficking cases over the place it's a
very busy task force and my opinion is
often in society we ignore it and we
ignore the vulnerable victims
yes contemporaneous with the arrest of
Epstein
you
that was a search pursuant to a valid
warrant agency's evidence including nude
photographs of what appear to be
underage girls yes I'm sorry what was
that
no comment
[Music]
he flew into the jurisdiction and so we
arrested I have no comment with respect
to the alleged victims yes we think he's
a significant flight risk and that is
why we are seeking detention pending
trial he has an enormous wealth the
charges are very serious and they carry
with him the maximum sentence of 45
years in jail which to someone of
Epstein's age is basically a life
sentence so we think he has every
incentive to try and flee the
jurisdiction and when you have two
planes and you live much of the year
abroad you know we think that's a very
real risk no comment I can't go into the
specifics with respect to any particular
victim
no comment well it's extremely
significant because of the number of
years and the number of victims there
are dozens of victims as alleged in the
indictment in New York and dozens in
Florida and it maintained itself over
several years so this is very
significant our office has handled this
year in fact many significant sex
trafficking cases and this is one of
them well as alleged in the indictment
you know these individually the underage
girls were sometimes recruited by
current victims and the current victims
were given cash payments if they could
bring other underage girls to be
similarly abused and that's how he
continued to expand the number of new
victims that he had that's how I was
able to maintain itself over several
years the the indictment indicates that
there were phone calls and contacts made
not only with mr. Epstein but his
employees between his employees and the
large victims
no comment
well it's it's still a very important
case and it means a great deal to the
alleged victims here that they have
their day in court and we want to ensure
that they had their they have their day
in court by bringing these charges we
are certainly aware of that reporting
thank you